[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir michel larive
député la france insoumise de l'ariège
bonsoir michel larive merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés pierre frédéric billets
mer les républicains de dreux bonsoir
müstair frédéric weill et merci d'être
avec nous il faut calmer le jeu vient de
nous dire à l'instant omar soumaré
pointant du doigt principalement des
programmes des problèmes on l'a entendu
de communication et de compréhension
avec la police vous pierre frédéric
bihel élu d'une ville avec une banlieue
pas toujours rose simple vous vous
partagez ce diagnostic
oui la question qui se pose en réalité
toujours la même c'est à dire entre la
prévention l'action qu'on peut mener sur
le terrain et puis la répression qui est
tout tout à fait nécessaire vous savez à
dos une année longue expérience dans ce
secteur là effectivement on a connu des
années qu'ils étaient difficiles on a
mis en place à l'époque mon prédécesseur
le pas ce qui était une sorte de
combinaison entre de la prévention de
l'action sociale mais aussi de la
répression plus de police municipale de
la vidéoprotection et en 25 ans on à
diminuer la délinquance à dreux de 40%
alors que dans le même temps au niveau
national la délinquance avait augmenté
de 10 points donc on peut faire des
choses sur le terrain on peut on peut se
mobiliser mais il faut que tous les
acteurs se mobilisent c'est à dire les
services de la ville et les services de
l'état les associations au regard des
résultats qui sont probants pour notre
population
on entendait également omar son marais
dit il ya seulement deux patrouilles a
un qui tournait la majorité du temps et
bien c'est pour faire les gros bras dans
ces conditions à ce qu'on peut vraiment
faire revenir l'ordre républicain avec
cette vision michel larive
toute violence et les
oiseaux comme cette discussion après ce
qui s'est passé à rillieux la pape
c'est malheureusement
je lis nous allons toujours les mêmes
constats et nous connaissions portant
des causes les causes elles sont
sociales j'entends ce que dit monsieur
le maire
j'acquiesce à beaucoup de ses propos
maintenant c'est aussi cet abandon des
services de proximité des services
publics
de toute cette paupérisation aussi de
ces quartiers qui font que effectivement
il ya un moment donné un vide république
tient qui s'installe la nature ayant
horreur du vide d'autres s'ils s'y
installent et peut-être par les
meilleurs d'entre nous maintenant il ya
effectivement des solutions les
solutions c'est de revenir de reprendre
place de redonner des moyens à la police
de proximité pas forcément
des policiers qui sont là pour le
chiffre mais essayer justement comme le
disait ce jeune homme 2 d'entrer en
relation avec les populations moi j'ai
une proposition nous avons des
propositions à faire c'est la relation
police citoyens grâce pourrait être
organisé des rencontres annuelles
notamment dans chaque cas d'espèce à
l'initiative des collectivités je pense
pas le seul mais redonne faire chasser
dans d'autres villes il faut trouver des
solutions et ses solutions sont sociales
parce qu'il ya quarante ans que nous
parle de politique de banlieue et depuis
40 ans
rien ne s'est amélioré bien au contraire
alors il faut vraiment vraiment prendre
le mal à la racine est là le mal et
social ces le manque d'emploi nombre de
services de proximité des commerces et
le manque de de service public tous ces
services publics sont partis ailleurs
nous avons la même discrimination avant
lui qu'on peut la voir dans le monde
global notamment dans mon département
c'est à dire que les gens se retrouvent
la seule seule phase effectivement à un
vide un vide républicain et donc
d'autres prennent la place et c'est tout
à fait dommage et je crois qu'il faut
que l'état reprenne qui est pas
seulement les collectivités
territoriales à qui on demande beaucoup
et à qui on ne donne pas forcément les
moyens notamment financiers
je crois que l'état doive revenir avec
les services publics avec une police de
proximité pas seulement de renforcement
de bacs de choses sous deux ou deux
autres structures comme celle là mais
des polices de proximité vous parlez de
caméras monsieur le maire j'entends ceux
ci mais la relation humaine comme le
précise ce jeune dans ce reportage
auparavant est tout aussi important je
pense que c'est si c'est d'ailleurs la
première chose à faire est c'est ce qui
se faisait à un moment donné parce qu'il
se faisait un moment donné alors deux
patrouilles par jour je pense que les
policiers sont eux aussi mal à l'aise
que la population un moment donné il va
falloir rétablir le contact est surtout
repenser ses banlieues repenser ce
domaine et comment on rétablit ce
contact 1 dont parle michel larive vous
êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic il faut
ramener les services publics dans dans
les cités et d'ailleurs pourquoi ça a
disparu on va pas reparler la police de
sécurité avec monsieur sarkozy m'enfin
y'a pas que ça c'est un manque de
volonté politique
qu'est ce qu'on sait comment l'expliquer
il ya plusieurs choses dans ce que vient
dire monsieur député et on était la
question et bluebay les complexes si on
veut avoir des résultats il faut
intervenir hier massive l'anru qui a été
lancée à l'époque par jean louis borloo
en 2003 est un très bon exemple toutes
les collectivités qui se sont lancés
dans la rénovation en profondeur des
quartiers ont des très bons résultats
donc on l'a fait sur l'ensemble urbain
dhr vernouillet
la première phase a consisté à investir
211 millions d'euros pour raser des
quartiers reconstruire des maisons des
petits collectifs etc en remettant des
commerces au coeur on a tout un
dispositif à dreux 2 mai les quartiers
qui ont des conseils citoyens qui ont
des investissements qui vont de la
formation sur l'ambiance du quartier on
travaille en lien avec la police
municipale la police nationale les
associations les centres sociaux pendant
train de remettre en place bref c'est
une action globale parce que peut pas
traiter la chute on est tous d'accord
n'était pas traitée de manière
répressive uniquement ou de manière
préventive uniquement voyez il il ya des
choses qui sont qu'on peut traiter de
manière plus douce ou de manière plus
subtile et puis des choses qu'on ne peut
pas laisser passer et c'est là où l'état
tout son rôle à jouer notamment l'anru
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie question
pour tous les maires qui ont n'est qu'un
tyran rue où est mon but aujourd'hui on
se pose vraiment beaucoup de questions
alors la sécurité en tout cas on l'aura
bien compris en ce début de deux
campagnes déjà bien amorcée peau pour
certains tous des candidats à la
présidentielle présentent leurs petites
recettes emmanuel macron tiens prenez
lui qui n'est pas encore déclarée promet
par exemple de doubler sur 10 ans la
présence de policiers et de gendarmes
sur le terrain ça doit vous faire
plaisir michel larive c'est ce qu'il
faut clairement parce qu'on sait pas
forcément ce que demande le jeune qu'on
a qu'on a rencontrés
non madame oui mais
ça suffit pas monsieur le maire l'a très
bien dit il lui faut à partir du moment
où il ya des vies qui nous ait des
riches donc à partir de ce moment là il
faut de la répression mais il faut aussi
la prévention mais qu il faut repenser
les choses vous paraît de sécurité donc
d'insécurité
l'insécurité sociale déjà cette
insécurité sociale qui fait que dans ce
dans cette danse dans 16 zones urbaines
là il ya une paupérisation ti fric de
toute manière cette insécurité sociale
va mener à un décalage
sociétal c'est très clair il se passe là
alors lorsque les moyens ne sont à la
potion si vous donniez justement au
moyen de la famille il y avait des
artistes qui sont pas les meilleures
pourquoi parce que l'emploi n'est pas là
parce que le l'habitat vous parlez de
rénovation monsieur le maire vous avez
tout à fait raison il faut repenser la
rénovation urbaine des quartiers il faut
favoriser les transports collectifs le
jeune homme disait moi j'allais au kayak
j'avais d'ailleurs il faut il faut que
les gens puissent sortir des quartiers
il faut qu'on puisse avoir la des pôles
de santé il faut qu'on puisse avoir la
dépose de sport culture et puis et puis
il sans oublier bien sûr c'est police de
proximité qui doit être là mais en
contact une police républicaine en
contact avec la population résidente
dans l'état
février c'est vrai que ce débat
malheureusement on l'a souvent pas que
sur ce plateau mais voilà dans la
société en général c'est vrai qu'on
entende et il faut il faut mais pourquoi
on n'y arrive pas pourquoi est-ce aussi
compliqué est ce que c'est un manque de
volonté politique est ce que la réalité
est plus difficile finalement ce sont
des des choses difficilement mais pardon
difficilement metab en oeuvre ses
loisirs sur le terrain oui c'est
forcément compliqué savez il faut pas
avoir d' idéologie là dessus il ya un
cadre républicain il faut le faire
respecter moi je pense aussi aux forces
de l'ordre qui font un travail
fantastique tous les jours et parfois je
continue parce que je me dis mais mais
quel travail c'est c'est un puits sans
fond parfois il ya des choses très
graves qui se passe et des réponses
pénales est pas au niveau et moi je
pense aux gendarmes et aux policiers qui
ne sont des fois désespéré par le
travail et enfin moi je suis admiratif
de l'entrain et très franchement ce avec
moi en plus je viens du ministère de
l'intérieur donc je connais bien cette
problématique là mais savez la police de
proximité
on l'a supprimé on voulait leur mettre
en place et c'est en réalité sur
beaucoup de communes en france elle est
réelle puisque les conventions police
nationale police municipale existe et
selon la volonté du maire et du
commissaire de police ou du préfet dans
un département à se mettre en place il
ya le clspd savez le contrat local de
sécurité connaissons la délinquance avec
la convention et nous a dream of et or
met des gens en pédestre on met des gens
en contact aller voir les commerçants
etc steira il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
zone de non droit à drulhe on va partout
parce que il ya une assise
d'accompagnement associatif social et
qui est assez assez puissante une police
qui est de proximité et quand il ya des
choses plus compliquées on sait aussi
intervenir au bon niveau bref il faut
voir des choses proportionnée et puis
surtout il faut aller dans les champs
alors du côté de jean luc mélenchon a on
avance des propositions dans le
programme l'avenir en commun on les a
regardés page 22 par exemple la france
insoumise veux faire je cite la police
républicaine regardez c'est donc ces
propositions de ont été retenus par
notre attention pour ce débat de ce soir
programme les venir en commun vous
proposer michel larive de démonter la
bac est de légaliser l'usagé du cannabis
pour désencombrer désencombrer la police
c'est ça qui va ramener selon vous du
lien social
alors vous avez pris deux mesures qui
font ch et ils m'ont paris on a bien
d'autres
démences et les bacs pourquoi
dans ces banlieues c'est pas de manquer
des services qui sont spécialisés dans
dans certaines situations dition
compliqué quelquefois c'est au vu de ce
qu'il fait pas fait regardez là
dernièrement pour un ticket de métro un
jeune homme d'un père l'homme vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ça c'est compliqué
alors non si vous savez l'aboutissement
de la violence d'où qu'elle provienne
c'est la mort on le voit on le re tous
les jours ah non donc à partir de ce
moment là il faut nous disons qu'il faut
une police républicaine pour
la population pour le peuple et pour le
peuple comme toute chose en service
public donc à partir de ce moment parce
que dans cette proposition ensuite sur
la légalisation du cannabis la
légalisation du cannabis je ne parle
seul à le dire je peux ya aussi dans la
majorité beaucoup et même 1 dans le
groupe heller d'autres commencent à dire
effectivement c'est une proposition qui
pourrait régler en tout cas le problème
d'offre et de demain et qui pourrait
régler le le cas dans tous les cas de
figures de ce marché parallèle qui se
met en place alors là dessus aussi il y
à dire c'est que la pole la police parce
que c'est les contraintes qu'on lui a
donnée est dans une politique de
chiffres et donc elle elle fait sa
politique de chiffrer le coût donc
arrêtez ça il faut
essayer de donner des moyens pour
essayer de
régler les affaires judiciaires et pas
seulement faire du chiffre et régler les
affaires judiciaires en amont c'est à
dire peut-être sur des trafiquants un
peu plus important il faut peut-être à
sécher les trafics en amour et puis et
puis revenir effectivement vers une
police plus
choqué dans les quartiers une police qui
sera de toutes petites fuites il faudra
être qu'elle soit quelque part
c'était par la population puisque la
populaire la police est républicaine
aussi ce n'est pas un service à part
c'est un service public comme tous les
autres services publics donc au service
des populations donc effectivement nous
proposons qu'elle le soit autrement fait
c'est le cas aujourd'hui alors à droite
justement proposition de xavier bertrand
candidat présidentiel qui a présenté son
programme sécurité le 15 septembre
dernier regardez
ce que je propose c'est la mise en place
maintenant de peines minimales
obligatoires il n'y aura plus d'impunité
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on change de
comportement avec nos policiers et nos
gendarmes nos mères c'est un voeu
peut-être pieux retour des des peines
plancher c'est la bonne idée pierre
frais dernier
oui c'est une piste qui était assis
récurrente est con
on a pu explorer après il ya les
modalités de mise en place mais je pense
que vous avez bertrand a
fondamentalement raison maintenant je
voulais les joueuses je vous venir sur
sur un point qui me semble important la
police française et républicaine par
définition intrinsèquement faut pas
confondre dans toute profession il ya
des écarts il ya à l'igpn qui sanctionne
j'ai pas de doute là dessus sur la bac
bon démente et là bas que je suis plus
réservé parce qu'il nous faut des
interventions de type spécialisés on
changera le nom savez c'est un peu comme
lennar ont supprimé la ordonna nouveau
nom mais ça reste l'ena en fait mais oui
il faut des fois des missions plus
musclée je pense que les évolutions
aussi à faire sur l'inspection générale
de la police nationale c'est une vraie
question et ça c'est un débat de fond
bon maintenant sur le cannabis au prix
environ débat j'ai ma position de
celui-ci mais je pense que là ce soir
c'est ce qui est un peu trop long
michel larive finalement on vous voit
pas beaucoup beaucoup de deux points de
discorde tous les deux il ya un lien
entre la france a soumises et et les
républicains quand on se retrouve
peut-être sur le seul sur le terrain
justement de ces quartiers difficiles
écoutez nous sommes tous les deux
républicain jonh en félicite j'ai
vivement je vais pas moi donner des
leçons à monsieur le maire qui lui est
sur le terrain de la commune c'est le
premier espace d obliger tocqueville
disait quelque chose comme ça et bien à
partir de ce moment là j'ai le plus
grand respect pour l'oeuvre de monsieur
le maire et des gens sur le terrain donc
je vais m'acheter loi j'ai mon idée nous
sommes un mouvement politique nous avons
des idées et sont en contradiction
souvent avec le mouvement les
républicains mais quand il s'agit de la
république et il s'agit de nos enfants
effectivement on peut trouver
[Musique]
des choses
titi monde et des choses lui qui vont
dans le même sens et bien pour moi c'est
très très grave je dire si jamais on va
vers la vie et pas vers le mans ce jeune
homme est mort pour un ticket de métro
donc moi je suis ici monsieur le maire
me dit le oui je suis d'accord en mai +2
de gens au contact de la population
c'est ce que nous voulons aussi on peut
pas contredire monsieur le maire pour le
contredira principe s'il le faut le dire
assez bien à puis voilà et donc à partir
de ce moment là nous avons si nous avons
des désaccords sur futures et manière de
faire une pression sur itunes merci en
tout cas à tous des deux messieurs de la
rive pierre fédérer levier d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce débat ce soir merci à
vous